dr anthony voucher slamming his critics
accusing them being anti-science our
next guest is firing back arguing the
only one ignoring science is dr fauci
gop center rand paul sits on the senate
hope committee joins us now and sparred
quite often with mr science
senator first off that's like if people
criticize me saying you just don't like
talk show hosts or you just don't like
senators if they criticize you
what kind of ego is this to say i
represent science
it's sort of a way of ending all debate
because if you attack him or have any
debate over any of his edicts or his
mandates you're attacking science but
this is a very very dangerous sort of
idea the idea that a government
bureaucrat represents science and that
he is now untouchable that it is sort of
like you are now contradicting the
all-high priest of science if you say
anything but there are real questions
and there's real areas of science that
he's never never really debated because
he deflects one area is over a hundred
million americans have had coven they
have natural immunity there's a real
question about whether they should be
vaccinated once twice or not at all and
the thing is there's never been a debate
because
he's the all-powerful scientist you're
not to question him just do as you're
told so with him it's more about
submission but most of his edicts are
not based in science whether kids should
wear masks in school is a very debatable
subject and ought to be debated in
sweden no kids wear masks 1.8 million
kids they haven't worn masks in school
at all for the last two years and they
haven't had any deaths and you say well
what about the teachers well it turns
out the teachers don't get covid at a
greater rate than the rest of the public
so it turns out maybe we don't have to
have our kids in masks should we have a
debate no dr fauci says he is the
all-powerful oz and we shouldn't
question him that's a real problem in a
free country he has a specific problem
with you and senator cruz for senator
cruz he said what happened on january
6th what does a doctor care about what
happens on january 6th or 7th or 5th i
mean what does that tell you where his
mind is at clearly you're under his skin
it shows you that he's a ranked partisan
but you know you've seen how he pushes
back now he just calls everyone else
liars so there's large randomized
studies there's a study from denmark
y'all reported on it on mask six
thousand people with masks six thousand
people without mask it turns out they
both had the same incidence of disease
eighty percent of those getting coveted
today are wearing a mask most of the
time so there's a question should we be
mandating something
every state province or country that
mandated mask wearing not one of them
showed the trajectory of the disease
going down the disease kept doing what
it wanted the only thing that affects
this disease are vaccines and also
natural immunity but the one thing
they're ignoring if he wants to talk
about the science the current vaccine's
not working very well worked very well
in april of may of this year when cases
went down to less than 10 000 a day but
it's not working very well they have a
delta variant vaccine they've had it for
months how come they're not producing it
how come it's not out there are we going
to need a new vaccine finally the head
of moderna is saying yes we're probably
gonna need a new vaccine but that's what
we should be talking about how come we
don't get a new vaccine every year or so
the way we do for the flu and how do we
make it easier for a new vaccine they
criticize trump to death for for his
bringing forward the vaccine within a
year they've done nothing to bring
forward a new vaccine they just keep
telling us to wear a mask and other
things that don't work yeah dr fauci
takes credit for that vaccine now it's
amazing real quick do you have the
supply chain crisis the president
canceled a presser on this
are we doing enough to stop this to help
this uh crisis
i think it's most important that people
know that it seems to be a supply chain
crisis that seems to be mostly in
heavily regulated california people need
to realize that when you try to put out
a business independent contractors like
lyft uber and independent truckers that
it's a problem you can't drive a truck
into california that has an engine older
than 2010 they're like nazis when it
comes to looking at your log to make
sure you're obeying the edicts on how
many hours you drive so truckers don't
go to california so truckers are in
other places there has to be a reason
why there doesn't seem to be this
problem in florida or doesn't seem to be
this problem on the atlantic coast yeah
that would be interesting senator rand
paul thanks so much thank you hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now